so one thing to think about as you think
about your own financial literacy is
what do you do in a situation where you
try to interact with some type of a
business or a financial institution and
they either are misinforming you in some
way or they're not doing what they said
they would do for example let's say that
you buy something online and you give
the payment you give the credit card and
they take the money from you but they
don't send you what you thought they
were going to send you or let's say you
buy a product and it breaks immediately
and maybe it's still in warranty but
they don't really fix that who could you
turn to
well the main entity in the United
States for that is known as the Better
Business Bureau sometimes BBB for short
and it's actually an independent
not-for-profit but it exists for this
exact reason if there is a business that
you think is doing not so great business
practices you can file a complaint with
the Better Business Bureau and they
actually will log that complaint and
they keep track the same way that
businesses or financial institutions
keep track of your credit score the red
the Better Business Bureau keeps scores
or ratings for businesses on how good
their business practices are and it's
somewhat measured by the complaints that
people are putting in on that business
and to what degree those complaints are
actually legitimate now there's it's not
just about buying a product or whether
someone fixes a product or warranty
there's also situations where people
might use misinformation or maybe not
complete information or not complete
education to take advantage of you the
the consumer there's a lot of situations
if you go back into actually just world
history where especially financial
institutions say hey give us a little
bit of this money and we'll invest it in
really good ways and it's gonna come out
really well or we'll give you this loan
and you know there's no strings attached
but maybe there are some strings
attached or maybe it was a more more of
a loan than you realize you were getting
into or there's certain aspects of the
loan that might get you in trouble and
to help prevent that there is a federal
agency called the Consumer Financial
Protection board it came out of the
banking crisis of 2011 when there were a
lot of folks who were kind of not given
all the details or maybe didn't have all
of the the necessary information to make
a decision about taking out a big loan
well maybe the interest rate will change
dramatically go up they didn't realize
the risks that were involved of taking
out a big loan for an asset that was
very speculative maybe the price of that
might go down like a house in an area
where the house housing prices have just
gone up a lot and and and more extreme
samples there's things like payday loans
where fairly vulnerable folks might go
into these loans not understanding the
interest involved which is ginormous to
use a technical word so that's what the
Consumer Financial Protection board does
is to make sure that folks are informed
that people aren't doing misinformation
or taking advantage of people's lack of
knowledge now those are the two big ones
on a federal level but there's also
going to be other groups there's groups
that help monitor the types of
Securities that might get issued you
might say well what's the security well
it's things like a stock or a bond and
as you can imagine if there's some kind
of shady company that really has nothing
behind it but says hey here's some
shares and these Shares are in the
newest hot thing like it's you know it's
artificial intelligence biotech whatever
whatever A lot of people might say oh
I'm just going to buy those shares
without realizing there's no company
behind it and so you also have groups
that regulate things like Securities you
have groups that regulate especially at
a state level insurance it's one thing
for someone to say they're going to
insure you and collect your premium but
when you when the bad thing actually
happens and you need to get the payout
are they going to be there for you
that's why insurance is pretty regulated
to make sure that the people who say
they're offering Insurance are actually
good for it so you need to be wary you
need to be careful but you should also
be conscientious that there are entities
out there that are there to help inform
and protect you